é bom dia é um prazer estar aqui a gente
vai trocar idéias aqui conversar um
pouco sobre a comunicação como um
direito humano e sobre a fotografia como
um dos instrumentos da comunicação e
como ela pode ser usada para quebrar
estereótipos e pensar um pouquinho sobre
o que é o estereótipo e talvez a gente
entender que o estereótipo
ele vem quando a gente informa para a
sociedade sobre uma pessoa sobre uma
comunidade
o shopping do país quase sempre a mesma
história se repete aquela história e
repete até aquela história até que
aquela comunidade aquela pessoa se
transformam naquela história
e aí eu queria antes da gente entrar
nessa discussão é colocar uma coisa que
é o que eu tenho aprendido no meu
correio de vida e eu quando eu comecei a
fotografar na maioria das pessoas com
quem eu trocava aprendizados e com quem
eu aprendia muito ao fotografar sobre a
vida
eram pessoas normalmente bem mais velhos
do que eu continue a fotografar e
continue adoro fotógrafo e hoje a
maioria das pessoas com quem eu continuo
aprendendo são normalmente bem mais
jovens do que eu e algumas coisas fui me
despertando né
uma das coisas que eu entendi é que
quando se cria um estereótipo dizia
afasta as pessoas que moram nessa
comunidade estereotipada da sociedade se
cria uma barreira um distanciamento e
quando a gente consegue contar
muitas histórias histórias diferentes da
história que sempre se conta dessa
pessoa
a gente ajuda a quebrar o estereótipo e
quando a gente quebra estereótipo agente
aproxima as pessoas e quando a gente se
aproxima as pessoas
a gente cria uma identificação em quem é
fotografado de quem se conta as
histórias com a maioria da população
recebe aquela informação
então eu acho que talvez a missão de um
documentarista
o grande barato que dá alegria ele
quando ele consegue ser um elo de bem
querer entre quem é fotografado e quem
vê as fotografias e aí eu pensando nisso
muito e um dia numa área quilombola de
noite vendo aquela beleza toda eu pensei
caramba porque é que não se formam quase
as belezas que acontecem distintos
espaços populares e aí eu vi é talvez
porque aproximasse tanto as pessoas né
se aproximando tanto as pessoas elas
começassem a ser mais ouvidas no seu
pedido de inovação de transformação ea
gente talvez mudasse estado escola
então acho que o estereótipo é muito
ligado também ao poder
e aí eu quero dizer que eu acho que tá
tá tão ligado e é tão contraditório com
a vida que eu pensei assim o que será
que une todos nós que estamos aqui né
o que será que une também toda a
população daqui de porto alegre
lá do rio de janeiro onde tem o projeto
imagens do povo
a população brasileira porque não atina
e aí eu entendi que tem uma coisa né que
é um pouco a história talvez os pais de
vocês seja muito parecida com a história
dos meus pais meu pai era um cearense
forte grande que veio foi para o rio
num pau de arara e lá ele conheceu minha
mãe que era uma carioca baixinha é
magrinha e acho que ele olhou pra ela
falou num bonitinha e acho que ela olhou
pra ele de alguma maneira vil beleza e
daí ele se chegaram e viram mais belezas
né que são as belezas dos seus fazeres
suas belezas interiores e aí foram
ficando foram ficando bom e eu sou um
dos sete filhos do seu tomado dona diná
eu acho que provavelmente a história dos
pais de vocês é muito parecida ver a
beleza o amor a beleza que eu falo da
sua beleza física mas a beleza dos
fazeres das pessoas elas juntam as
pessoas
olhe se a beleza se esse amor
ele é responsável pela existência da
humanidade
fica a pergunta por que na hora de se
informar nem informar faz parte do
processo de educação mas sim formar se
falar das populações menos favorecidas
não se mostra as belezas dos seus
fazeres quase todas as comunidades como
os moradores de favela trabalhadores
rurais quilombolas índios seringueiros
ribeirinhos mas todas essas populações
infelizmente são mostradas pela ausência
de quase tudo pela presença de uma
violência da qual na maioria das vezes
são vítimas mas aparecem muitas vezes
como protagonistas
e essa história a história que se repete
sobre eles
a gente quase não tem história dos
fazeres e aí eu fui pensar muito sobre
isso entendi uma coisa né
os fazeres são as expressões dos sonhos
e os sonhos são as expressões das
esperanças dos desafios
eu acho que pode ser tudo mas é muito
difícil censurar o sonho das pessoas
e eu via isso fotografando e via como
era bonita inúmeras cenas às vezes
situações das mais difíceis né
a agência tem em situações de
documentação de trabalho escravo
mas eu vi naquelas pessoas uma
resistência uma teimosia né de digno de
ser ousado de um dia transformar e de
seguir seus sonhos e entende que a
realização dos sonhos dela é
transformadora se ela é editora que ela
provoca
se ela for contada a gente vai ver
mudanças de estado esporte a gente vive
e aí eu entendi por que né que a
comunicação é um dos grandes poderes
talvez morte todos porque ele é um poder
em si enquanto poder da comunicação
ele é um poder que tem dentro e é usado
como ferramenta de todos os poderes
ele é usado como ferramenta dos poderes
dos países dominantes para expor suas
idéias e nas idéias divulgadas que
justificam massacres como da biafra só
se conta uma história uma história uma
história até que a população absorveu
esse massacre né
a mesma história também é contada sobre
as favelas onde passa a cst medo e
quando se passa por uma favela por
exemplo no rio parece ouvir aquela
musiquinha tantã e acontece que ele tem
inúmeras histórias e aí eu entendi que
esse poder que está dentro dos países
dominantes está dentro do nosso país
seja no governo federal estadual
municipal está dentro dos poderes da
indústria está dentro dos poderes do
comércio ou seja tá dentro das forças
dominantes e que não têm um interesse
muito grande ver mudar um status podem
mudar o processo de educação para um
processo transformador investigativo
onde você coexistia nem termos de
decisões em ti troca de saber com quem
está aprendendo ou com quem é jovem com
quem estudante e por quê
isso aí eu entendi como eles fazem isso
comecei a pensar você fotografa tanta
coisa fantástica tanto história incrível
e só vejo quase que sair as matérias que
condeno essas populações
entendi isso é vamos na edição na
escolha do que se vai divulgar
vamos bloquear as belezas vamos bloquear
os fazeres porque assim a gente deixa as
pessoas distantes da gente
e assim a gente também só passa para a
sociedade um determinado a história uma
história única e o perigo dessa história
não é necessariamente que ela seja uma
mentira
ela pode até ser verdade mas eu acho que
a gravidade do crime é que ela se
transforma na única história daquela
pessoa daquela comunidade daquele estado
daquele país daquele segmento de vida e
ninguém nem nenhum lugar tem uma só
história
então uma das coisas que eu entendi
muito foi isso que antes de entrar em
alguns projetos que a gente resolveu
fazer a partir daí é que existe uma
outra coisa também quer saber
compartilhado ea gente pensou como é
como fotógrafo
a gente pode de fato fazendo a formação
ea informação interagir né
ouve-se instigado instigar a gente então
tem discutido muito uma fotografia
compartilhada uma fotografia onde quando
você vai para uma comunidade é
documentar uma realidade que não bola
indígena e trabalhadores rurais podem
ficar bastante tempo poderá aprender
poder projetar e editar na frente das
pessoas e permitir que no que as pessoas
não se sintam representadas elas possam
pedir pra esse material foi retirado
z deletado e eles participarem desse
processo de
então a gente começa a ter uma resposta
muito forte e aí vim cada vez mais
entender como é gostoso quando você
consegue se ela né e prazer se elas têm
que entender que documentar é também
aprender sobretudo que não dá para você
chegar diante de um local de uma pessoa
como se você fosse detentor de um saber
e simplesmente é de ser cheio de câmeras
como se fosse um mar de natal e ficar
ali chamando atenção e documentando nem
quanto mais a gente é consegue interagir
ficar transparente não ser notado
talvez essa essa comunicação essa
informação seja um aprendizado e que a
gente vai contar essas histórias e
comecei também a entender que eu adoro
fotografia fotografia não vale mais que
mil palavras mas ela é muito melhor
junto com belas histórias né bom e foi
assim que um dia é o observatório de
favelas que é uma organização que
trabalha com direitos humanos e com a
educação é me convidou para fazer uma
documentação sobre favelas do rio onde
pudesse é mostrar outras histórias
e aí quando eu comecei a fazer o
trabalho eu percebi que existiam
inúmeras pessoas na favela
elas não se viam e nem gostavam ser
vistas da forma como eram mostradas e vi
também que existiam outras pessoas que
gostavam de fotografia que eram
fotógrafos iniciantes e outros que
queriam ser fotógrafos que queriam
mostrar uma outra favela
então eu cheguei com observatório
conversei que muito mais importante do
que fotografar a gente pensar numa
escola uma escola de futebol os
populares onde se criasse uma agência
junto onde as pessoas pudessem ter
bastante conhecimento da fotografia é do
que era a fotografia e o outro outra
pessoa quem você vai fotografar como era
poder se portar diante da dor dos outros
diante da alegria dos outros
e que a gente então também pudesse ter
nessa escola conhecimentos técnico
conhecimentos em linguagem fotográfica
ea gente criou a escola e eu me lembro
que o primeiro projeto que a gente
conseguir um financiamento bem pequeno é
foi por seis meses só eram aula todos os
dias quatro horas de aula por dia e eu
fiz com outro amigo meu documentarista
ricardo funcionário ea gente entendeu
que um projeto para continuar
ele tinha um ensino tinha uma discussão
de saberes com as pessoas é tinha uma
agência mas que era importante a gente
chamar pessoas mais capacitadas dentro
da nossa área capacitadas no ensino num
currículo pedagógico ea gente então
chamou uma outra pessoa foi o dante
gastaldoni professor das universidades
estaduais e federais que ficou
apaixonado pelo projeto
esse projeto tem dez anos depois com o
tempo a gente entendeu que tinha que
chamar alguém que também dominasse muito
bem a questão das agências porque era
difícil fotógrafos competirem no mercado
formal porque tinham discriminação só
pelo fato de morar em uma favela e aí a
gente trouxe aqui tá pedrosa que se
dedicou fantasticamente a isso e aí a
gente depois viu que era fundamental
abrir os horizontes de mercado isso que
a gente foi vendo foi ouvindo dos alunos
foi ouvindo dos cartórios se formavam
e aí a gente trouxe uma pessoa que a
joana mava para ver a relação da
fotografia com a arte e da entrada da da
fotografia enquanto arte enquanto
documentação no mercado feito por esses
fatores é hoje o projeto numa das fases
mas eu acho fortes e um sonho antigo que
a gente aprendeu com os próprios
fotógrafos que tinha que esperar mais
tempo que é o projeto que é o projeto
observatório de favelas chama imagens do
povo está sendo coordenada pelos
próprios
é um sonho que a gente tinha é dentro
desse projeto além de aprenderem
fotografia e hoje podem estar
transmitindo isso em outras favelas em
áreas rurais
a edição também no mercado estão
documentando a vida e eles estão
contando muitas histórias do que os
documentos estão fotografando da própria
favela contando muitas histórias e se
entendeu que o projeto também se faz com
o coletivo né
então cada um de nós hoje está num campo
está continuando o processo de
documentação
tá vendo esses fotógrafos como
companheiros nós e eu vou mostrar três
fotos aqui
essa foto é do ratão de nicho e mostra a
favela de manguinhos e na favela de
manguinhos onde mesmo antes da
pacificação tinha uma participação muito
grande de pinturas de artistas de
fotógrafos e essa é uma criança na
favela
vou mostrar uma outra foto aqui que é
denise é uma mãe debruçada sobre um
filho é e trouxe uma discussão muito
grande depois de um conflito na favela
de que a dor e o carinho das mães que
moram nas favelas também é igual a dor o
carinho das mães que moram em qualquer
espaço popular né em qualquer parte da
favela e eu queria colocar essa foto é
que é do adriano
sendo assim começa a contar a história
na favela do que durante um conflito com
a polícia por causa de uma manifestação
começa a contar essa história do
conflito por um pai que protege o seu
filho correndo desse conflito começa
pela história dos moradores talvez a
gente crie bastante outras histórias
talvez a gente comece a poder aproximar
os moradores das favelas e os demais
espaços populares da população como um
todo
então é essa a ideia que eu queria
trazer aqui
queria agradecer pois sei que esse tempo
obrigado